[Music]
good morning John it's Thursday December
15th I think 13th
Kathir than that going out in the car it
hasn't moved in a while to do some stuff
and we're taking you with us
we started off of course at the post
office it was very busy we use the
electronic teller it was faster but gone
to you bathroom wrote everything no
textual communication and then we moved
on to the post office so Hank what are
you and Katherine doing we're buying
Christmas trees do you think we're bad
people it's more of a decoration really
for our party and also a place to put
all of our lovely Christmas ornaments
which we love so much and have had since
we were little babies there's not very
many left
apparently not the best time to country
Christmas trees something like a dozen
or so with all these like places where
they used to be Christmas trees and now
there's not anymore but such is life the
good news is that they're on SuperDuper
sale because there's like 11 days to
Christmas what happened on the eleventh
day of Christmas drummers drumming I
think so it looks like we're gonna get a
tree for about 15 bucks which is good
for me I'm sure with that that's about
how much I want to pay announce them for
our friend to bust out the electric saw
and cut off the end of the tree for us
so that it will be healthy healthier
I guess as it slowly succumbs to entropy
rotting in a corner of our house thanks
for dying for us mr. tree we appreciate
it
your life is worth 15 dollars that's a
pretty good deal the guy who saw was the
tree was a kind of an extreme character
he's an actual Montana who are pretty
much outnumbered now in Missoula so it's
good to see that I don't think they have
the hardy individuals they used to have
seen the old days before the regular
Montana
in the Hills snow snow a lot of folks
just aren't doing that anyway yeah and
then we came home and put up the tree
killed viewers may have by now noticed a
trend a strange and disturbing trend
something that I didn't notice myself
until I want to this footage every step
of the way
Catherine is the one doing the work I'm
sorry baby but I gotta fill my videos
our wives are also getting a reprieve on
January from Japan uary whatever defend
you re first speaking of broken
electrical signals in my brain 11 pipers
piping but strangely there are actually
12 days until Christmas and 12 is
drummers drumming oh that was me miming
the electrical signals of my brain
getting crossed changing the subject
from me being lame to nerdfighters being
awesome the response to the secret
project is going extremely well but
there's something else that I want to
share with you right now
that's pretty amazing Pete buck just
sent me an email that he got from Miriam
Webster dear Pete okay there's like not
actually anything on this page babe my
printer doesn't work and if it did I
wouldn't print out any emails anyway
because it's bad for the environment so
I'm just gonna look over here for a
second dear Pete thanks for the email we
got quite a lot of letters concerning
nerdfighter sadly mm of the word of the
year poll is closed but we do hope that
you'll include nerdfighter and
nerdfighting in our open dictionary etc
etc you're as a nerd fighting corey
stamper associate editor merriam-webster
maybe next to you guys but seriously I
mean who gets a letter from
merriam-webster the dictionary people
are taking notice of us John they know
I've been wanting to share with everyone
including you John though obviously you
know about this because it is a message
on my phone from you subscribed oh I
don't know why this matters to us but it
really does so thank you thank you for
everyone who kicks ass and make sure
that I do point or something that we
really actually an extremely
surprisingly love love love to do thank
you all very much John I will see you
tomorrow